I mean thank you guys for coming and we
have QA so if you guys we have current
one of our other teammates he's got a
mic if you guys have questions we would
love to have ladies answer we did Dan
Allen take it alright then you can come
and take my mic Ron has one run has one
he's just a button-up they fear the
challenge or Mary Lou's question it's
ladies night so Mary Lou goes first okay
all right we got our red over we got the
mics coming right now we waiting for
well it's important as we're recording
the audio that's why yeah yes yeah this
is awesome I
you're awesome I came because I knew
Nicola Mariana and got to McKenzie and
as I heard he talked I'm older than all
of you and I think it turned seven in
1972 and I don't think the conversation
has changed very much since then yes
we're beyond slavery but it's been the
same conversation every decade with the
same women and it's not moving forward
in the backdrop of this of the hearings
yesterday is just somewhat appalling I'm
the same age as Brett Kavanaugh and you
know when I'm reference checked it comes
out that I'm assertive aggressive
ambitious in other words I don't get to
hear about and I don't get the job and I
just I wonder if you can speak to that
on this night I actually haven't seen
any of the things cuz I've been busy
working because I have a job and sure
you guys too but sorry tough question
and weekends be great to meet you and I
came just because you're the future you
are the future amazing what you've said
so are you
what quite what was the quiet we what's
the final so the question is has the has
the conversation evolved I think the
thing that I get frustrated with like
I'm speaking at a small satellite
conference which if any of you want to
talk about really old stodgy industries
like come hang out in the space race
with me and it's infuriating and I'm on
this this panel that's about like
culture and space companies and I kind
of yelled a little bit because I am NOT
a serene and it's my amazing
co-panelists on the call that was like
the prior to panel prep and I basically
said that I was like this conversation
has not evolved and I am so sick of
participating and I think this
conversation was interesting but like
the the ones of like how do we do a
better job with diversity and so I think
that the thing that we have to do is
stop applauding ourselves for having the
conversation and get really functional
say like okay great what are the tools
like how do we fix it what do you know
how do we how do we not only enable but
proliferate cognitive diversity in our
workplaces and how do we allow people
who aren't comfortable speaking up to
have the tools and the channels in which
to do so and how does technology enable
that and that's why I get so excited
about the things that like Mary Lou is
building with this like brain to brain
interaction where you know maybe we have
a set of tools in the future where we
can start understanding each other
because we're bad at creating it in
social context and maybe he just like
plug in to each other's matrix and have
some deeper understanding at some player
conscious so I don't know how we advance
the conversation but I'm working really
hard to fund technologies that help us
advance the conversation because we kind
of suck at it and I don't know how to
fix that
but I'm with you I'm still frustrated
can I ask you a question merely the
do you have you seen a difference in the
I know you said it's the same
conversation the same outrage but one of
the things that feels different to me
from a few years ago is like the like I
think I think women are getting way more
aggressive and I'm happy about that like
it's like things that used to be okay
that that people used to be able to get
away with they're not able to completely
get away with it anymore
and I a part of that I guess is social
media and some other things but it seems
like it's way more visible and that
there's that there are at least some
consequences do you do you think that
that yes and I think that your point
about slavery and it's it's so long ago
or is it so long ago I mean that there
the civil rights movement not very long
ago this social change is so
pathetically slow and and yet I suppose
yeah sure it's it was Anita Hill in 1991
and this is a little bit better now
there's a one-week FBI isn't okay so
that's progress yes it's Minh to college
with the guys like that in high school
and guys like that I am the same age as
Brett Kavanaugh it is seems to be better
now that people seem to be appalled but
like it's just so rare that you three
exist it's so rare that some of us in
the room exist and it could be and yet
we have kind of football players that
get drunk every night that get to swirl
in the same you know the mediocre men
who prevail and the from what I've seen
the the acts absolutely appalling views
of of the old white male senators that
exist that still control our our
government and they will die yes they
will die they're old
and there will be new we won't
unfortunately live forever a Kurtz while
I believe is wrong but it's just so pain
how do we speed this up because we're
you know the anger and fear in the love
yeah those are the emotions but how do
we it just seems so so appallingly so
and even as Gloria Steinem says she gets
exhausted at sometimes when she looks
back at her career and she's taken these
multi-year breaks where she doesn't work
on women's rights because it's so damn
exhausting and then she gets like okay I
took a decade off I'll get back into it
but like Minh
at wit's end after just reading and not
even seeing the stuff in the last two
days and just this being the Friday
night after Senator flake who I'd never
heard of before decided I mean why does
it take somebody called senator flake
because who's I basically you know
chased down in an elevator by women's
sexual assault survivors to sort of flip
in like okay we can have a one-week
investigate like it seems very slow I
think for me from my perspective cuz
that come on very masculine I was raped
my mom has nine brothers and sisters so
there's ten of them out of the ten seven
them are female and they're like bolder
shoulders like they just don't they're
just you know they're just very strong
women they're not even strong they just
they just and maybe because they just
had to come together to stay together
because my grandparents died when they
were all fairly young so they had to
they kind of had to they were raised to
be tough
and survival but they've taught me three
words cut the head was it cut yeah
and you have to be aggressive and just
go for it and a lot of women were not
taught to do that you know what men are
taught to do that yeah straight on yeah
but we agree that's a good press for
people but there's this community we
need more women tonight give a I'm not
gonna say the word but we need more
women can I give a [ __ ] and just go for
it and that's and that's it and so we me
and tell you just go it's I would say
it's more telle than me because men
especially in the Caribbean they're
saying oh you little girl and I almost
like it well I'm 37 years old what is he
talking about
is there like oh no you have little
girls and I'm like okay oh you know so
it's yeah I punch people right exactly
so then you just have to just tape that
hey doll you don't have to be overtly
emotional but you do have to have a
tactic and a strategy and you just have
to just there's no wrong or right way to
do it just don't get overtly emotional
and just and just and just throw it back
in their face you know and men don't
like that so very little I may have
something interesting because you say
cut the head for the for women like go
for it be aggressive get your goal get
that what you want I think for men or at
least for me and I think for several
other men that maybe follow the juicy
heart mentality is this idea of looking
at the trauma and feeling the most
visceral parts of the trauma of what we
went through with slavery and what we
went through with Native American so we
went through with women and feeling it
in as much fullness as possible and then
helping others integrate it into their
being and then being able to move
forward as an ally for equality of
opportunity
me from a man's perspective yeah yeah I
think that irrational man would think
that way yeah to think that way
just he's like a boomerang whatever they
throw at you you throw it back at him
you know that's the only way they're
going men like that are going to learn
yeah I like that t-shirt so I will be
super quick I just wanted to thank you
so much one of the most interesting
panels there was that because of the
diverse opinions you have and your
ability and speakers as well Alan that
was amazing
I'm so glad I'm here I wish more people
hurt you Nicole if I would know what
kind of gem you are as a speaker I would
never let you go when I met you before
you promised me to come to some event
and speak again thank you
and I'm embraced by all of you just
Nicole I saw her already I met her and I
need to run and I will reach out to all
of you and I will be convincing you to
come speak again thank you
Nicolle weather um what are some of the
meditation practices that you feel like
express your being the most or you like
the most so um my my first my first
awakening was through the plasma oh it's
like body scanning because I was a very
like head oriented mental person and the
pasta is like 10 days of body scanning
and I think that gave me balance I think
someone else who is very physical could
would do really well with very mental
techniques like direct inquiry or other
things like that so different things
work for different people currently I am
following Dan Brown not the novelist but
I he's a Tibetan Buddhist meditation
teacher he's an extraordinary teacher he
really understands how to teach to the
Western mind and so it's a open
awareness Tibetan bond so what I'm doing
right now
awesome all right we have we have more
time yeah we're turnin yeah go for it
correct so I was interested by what you
were saying about humanity's need for a
new narrative oh yeah and I've been
following you know not just what was
happening this week in Washington but
what's been happening sort of on an
ongoing basis and I've been wondering
you know companies from time to time
circumstances change right markets
changed culture changes governance
practices change and companies from time
to time will like go through a
restructuring it's like no big deal like
hey we're gonna move this department
around we're gonna change the way we
elect our board we're gonna you know do
do so on and so forth and I'm wondering
whether I know none of your as far as I
know subject matter experts in this but
as sort of unusually intelligent
laypeople
do any of you have thoughts on the
possibility of some kind of a
restructuring of North American
governance whether that might be
desirable what that might look like just
because I had lunch with Tim Draper a
couple weeks ago who was slightly been
championing the California session
movement I think there's an interesting
thing right I've spent a lot of time
looking at like countries come up with
these or anthropologists come up with
these like happiness vectors which are
as a scientist I kind of struggle with
self reporting data on happiness but
it's fine and so if you look like places
like Norway have these like ridiculously
high Happiness indices and people are
like well let's be like we're like
Norway and then you think okay well it's
a pretty mono-ethnic society with
excellent social welfare and honestly
just a very small population in a rather
landlocked place and I think about that
well if if that's actually what we want
to optimize for then maybe you want to
optimize for a bunch of self-similar or
city-state fracked like fracturing of
this massive diverse group because turns
out that you can't make most people
happy if you take a massive diverse
group of people and then try to apply
one set of constructs to them because
there's always gonna be a bunch of
people who are deeply upset from an
economic theory perspective that doesn't
really close a lot of the time and so I
end up reading a lot of science fiction
and I think about what the future looks
like when we move into a world where
what if people could like download other
people's consciousnesses and
you could just like vote as you know one
entity of a person who believes in a
particular class of philosophies and
then how do you break up like government
structures on that sense so I think as a
layperson in this space the way that I
think about it is the way the US is set
up right now feels really unstable and
also basically arcane but I'm not sure
that we'll know how to do anything
proactive about it without it kind of
self-destructing what I get really
excited about is I see a lot of
countries basically leaping all of us
like cross leaping all of our social
constructs like you see a lot of African
nations going mobile first distributed
currency first like really really
interesting technology is enabling
fundamentally different social
constructs in Africa because they don't
have all this like Electoral College
crap to you know get over and so we
probably frogging I think it's super
interesting what I fear is that we're
not gonna be able to leapfrog here so I
don't know how we leapfrog our own
current status but I'm super happy to
talk about this all day long yeah that's
a good writing prompt how to leapfrog
how do we leapfrog yeah I don't think
there's I think we have to I'm gonna
make there's three things someone the
same was trying to make them really
short first how this country was built
was in error that has to be corrected
and I think the best way to do that is
destroy it and start over
sorry it's just how today and also this
whole structure of conservative versus
liberal and you know I'm probably
shouldn't say this because I am
definitely a minority in a room but I am
a conservative in black conservatives
raised in the South I am a libertarian
Republican I'm a proud libertarian
Republican but I'm not a crazy but
publican
you know so I still agree with a lot of
my liberal colleagues and stuff and
people my age so I think at some point
we're gonna have to just leave those
labels just walk away from the both of
us and just do the right thing I'm
waiting for us to do that and I was
hoping our generation would do that I'm
really still hoping that it's us because
we're like nearing 40 years years like
like we'll be forward like molinos would
be 40 in a couple years and yeah we're
still doing we're still doing this and I
think that will probably solve the
problem that you're talking about we can
just keep going in this circle or
whatever but we're going into the circle
politically yeah yeah
yeah and yeah yeah but I think the next
generation I don't know if you guys have
any kids I don't have kids we have a lot
of little cousins or whatever they are
fearless
I think they don't really really do it
and then the last thing I want to say I
think because of technology for the
conversation let's just bring the mic
over quick yeah like that's why they're
there they're made to be cannon fodder
it is actually hormonal and that's why
the boys particularly are inscripted to
die on the sword and like it's not true
it's a great lie that's that's the
problem I have with it
it seems like a great lie that each
generation believes I think the next
generation is two things they don't
they're not gender male or female does
it it's not a thing to them so they're
growing up being having all these
different labels and stuff like that
it's not just male and female they have
other labels and also they don't respect
adults they know that we're wrong they
just they just know that were wrong and
they don't care and they will call out
an adult in a heartbeat and just been a
day in a public school just been a day
in a public school in middle America
they do not respect adults and their
little tyrants and I like it you know
but the third yeah it's not it's not new
but I think maybe because of technology
and I don't know I'm hoping I'm not
putting all the trust in technology but
I just see them being a lot more bolder
than than what we were we were taught to
we would leave a bluebird you know
raised on Care Bears and you know so I
don't really don't think it's so Mary
Lou maybe this doesn't hold but the one
thing that feels possibly new is for
every person who is actually on the
fringe because they're gay because they
don't feel like they fit into their
family because like whatever the reason
that they whatever set of constructs was
applied to them at birth and in their
community they shed and not just out of
like teenage rebellion but like truly
don't feel like a part of that it feels
easier for those people today to find
their digital tribes and feel more
comfort faster maybe I'm wrong but like
that that feels like a shift yeah so
maybe it takes like two or three
generations for that to like sing Kurt
can we just quickly bring the mic over
yeah I know I know I'm just trying so
hard to be enough so I'm feeling
particularly downtrodden too because
here we are and it's 2018 the Evangelic
and so-called christian patriarchy is
rearing its ugly head and is not dying I
think we have courts hordes of white men
supporting the rape of teenage girls now
to try to get somebody on the Supreme
Court and normalizing it so that is 2018
this week all right
trying to say who cares if you were
molested it's not significant and so I'm
just pushing back
on social change a business model that
needs to be exposed in my aunts a lawyer
and she's been threatened several times
on this but it's a business model in
America that needs to be talked about a
lot more and you know it's it's not
underground it's in our governments
deeply embedded in that and I think that
needs to be exposed I think that's the
next thing that needs to really really
be exposed well can I just say the third
thing I wanted to stay with his the
third thing I want to say very quick yes
okay really quickly so last week I spent
a week in Singapore and I was just
boasting about how awesome it is because
it was clean and was orderly and no
homeless people we had no people
screaming outside and and stuff like
that and at the end of the trip someone
told me oh well they're kind of quasi
communist no like what huh cuz I'm
conservative don't like wait a minute
this is not what they're talking about I
mean if this is if that's quasi like
what is it
quasi communist yeah yeah they do had a
death penalty I mean it's it's like I
said strange society like I'm in
Singapore yeah I don't like I liked it
maybe because I went in for business but
but I yes it illegal to chew gum but I
kind of liked I kind of liked that I was
even shocked that I did like that I did
like that and I embrace that experience
as a conservative so I think we're all
you know it's just roll it I think we're
going through this process of just
evolving we haven't got to the end of
this this age of whatever this stage of
life is so I think it'll all be on the
melting pot of everything hopefully the
good stuff I'm kind of at my head the
log drive yeah yeah that's that that's
it okay that's it this has been a great
Q&A section at the end of the women in
Alliance event awesome thanks everybody
for coming out thank you our panelists
so much next upcoming things that
got going on we got a an event coming up
in partnership with psychedelic seminars
on micro dosing on yeah on October 22nd
really looking forward to that
come and check that out Mission Bay
conference on October 22nd I'm giving a
TEDx talk on powerful questions on
October 9th which is really exciting and
then we'll have another couple cool
events on the future of Education the
future of social media in November so
look forward to those thank you
everybody for coming out
much love
[Applause]